foreign
I want to come back to something you
said which was talk to the customer
iterate talk to the customer iterate and
just to maybe State the obvious which is
very often
entrepreneurs try to iterate without
talking to the customer and one of the
things I appreciate about many of the
founders who've gone through y
combinator this includes the Airbnb
Founders and others is in the early days
doing things that don't scale right
really taking a manual approach to
interacting with customers what else
would you consider core principles or
learnings that you took away from y
combinator or polygram specifically or
anyone else involved
well I don't know if this came up in
your research but actually I worked at
Airbnb before starting coinbase so yes
indeed yeah I mean I was I think it was
Employee of 40 there or something like
that and then I got to learn a lot from
them too about yeah the perseverance and
how they ran product and all it was
really cool but I guess some of the
lessons just generally from that that
ecosystem because it all came from by
combinator and Airbnb and all that stuff
I mean another one of my favorite kind
of hologramisms is
action produces information right so
there's many times where you're sitting
around and you're like all right well
what if this happens what if that
happens and you're kind of staring into
the abyss like into the cloud the fog
ahead of you and you don't really know
what to do and so people sometimes get
stuck in those environments and they
just
they never take any action basically but
if you just take some steps into the
unknown you might not be doing the right
thing but oftentimes by doing that
action you'll realize what you should
have been doing instead there was a
great story that kind of went along with
this where the early days of coinbase
actually before it was even called
coinbase I was just tinkering on some
stuff nights and weekends while I was at
Airbnb and I remember
um I built this very simple app with a
friend of mine I think it was just
called Bitcoin wallet or something it
may still be on GitHub somewhere but it
was basically an Android app and we
decided hey we want to make
you want to make like a Bitcoin wallet
that runs on Android it was supposed to
be very simple right and we didn't have
any kind of cloud thing behind it it
wasn't any sort of a company or anything
like that and so we basically ran a full
Bitcoin node right on the Android phone
which at the time people might laugh at
it now but at the time Bitcoin nodes
were very small and lightweight and they
could run on phones and
so we coded this thing up and we
launched it I was just trying stuff I
didn't know what I was doing we weren't
even trying to make a company we were
just kind of like trying to learn this
stuff in the evenings in our free time
and I launched it I remember the minute
that we launched it that was like wired
wrote some little article about it I was
like wow that's so cool wired wrote an
article about it but the minute we
launched it I realized we had built it
wrong and the reason I realized that was
that we were trying to again we were
running the whole Bitcoin node right on
the phone and it would take forever like
every time you open the app it would say
syncing and it would have to sync like
for three four minutes or whatever to
catch up with the latest blockchain
blocks and so that was a good example
where like I knew it instantly we'd
built the wrong thing and then what went
off in my head was okay someone's gonna
have to make a company around this that
has a truly like a lot of this stuff
running in the cloud where you can do
all the backups and security and sync
with the blockchains and and I was in I
remember thinking at that time oh that's
not going to be me because I have a day
job and like that's a really serious
company to run and someone will probably
try to hack into it and it's like you
got to have like a lot of money for that
so I didn't I didn't immediately get to
the next step was maybe I'll start that
company but it that was a good example
of just taking action produced
information which made the next step a
little bit more clear